let's go to paul brennan now who's at
downing street hello there paul more
resignations this morning as johnson
prepares for prime minister's questions
and a grilling by senior mps later
that's right no uh cabinet ministerial
level resignations this morning but we
have had uh two people falling on their
swords and uh resigning uh in
frustration frankly at the way the
number 10 operation has been conducted
uh in recent days and weeks firstly
laura trotch is a ministerial aide a
parliamentary private secretary in the
transport department but more
interestingly a man called will quince
who is a minister for children and it
was he who was sent out to do the the
media interview round on monday morning
um saying that the prime minister knew
nothing about chris pincher's uh
problems and passed in actual fact that
version of events that uh will quince
had been given was false and chris uh
sorry wilkins uh feeling today that uh
he had no option frankly uh given that
embarrassment uh but to quit um that
said uh we have seen uh the defense
secretary ben wallace go into number 10
in the last half an hour uh no
indication that he is on his way out so
far he has expressed his support uh for
the prime minister's position uh so at
the moment uh a couple more resignations
but not at cabinet level and as you say
boris johnson is not out of the woods
not by any stretch of the imagination a
really tough day ahead prime minister's
questions uh is at 11 uh gmt a half hour
40 minute session in parliament uh with
the leader of the opposition but most
interestingly it would be good to watch
exactly what the
conservative backbenchers uh ask the
prime minister and what level of anger
they vent at him
but more importantly i think the liaison
committee is like a super committee of
35 chairpersons of all the individual
parliamentary committees they come
together it's a two-hour session
more likely to be far more forensically
um interrogation
of the prime minister i think he's going
to have a really tough time boris
johnson does like big broad brush
strokes to be
pinned down by a committee of committed
mps and committee chair people is not
something boris johnson's going to enjoy
for the two hours of this afternoon
session certainly a critical day ahead
paul and what about these calls for a
snap general election how likely is that
to happen
it's possible it's certainly an option
that
boris johnson's supporters have
put on the table uh
as he's losing support within the
conservative party uh the the thinking
was perhaps that if he went to the
government sorry to the country that he
might find more support there but that
option does seem to be ebbing away given
uh the results of a yougov opinion poll
uh by the by the company yougov
overnight uh which showed that uh 69
of people now believe that boris johnson
should resign and for the first time a
majority of conservative voting members
of the public also believe he should go
um previously it's been below 50 it's
now 54 percent of people who would vote
conservative now believe the prime
minister their conservative prime
minister uh should go um 68 percent of
the total though believe he will try at
least to fight on and there is no
indication at all that boris johnson
will willingly leave the address downing
street behind me uh it's just i mean his
track record shows that he is just not
the sort of person to quit willingly
all right thank you very much for
bringing us up to speed we'll cross back
to you throughout the day paul brennan
live for us outside downing street